- Lesia Vasylenko, ça nous fait
plaisir de vous retrouver ici,
à Kiev.
SISISIA VASYLENKO
députée, Parlement ukrainien
- Ça me fait vraiment plaisir
que vous êtes ici à Kiev et que
vous avez l'opportunité de voir
un peu le pays et de voir
comment ça se passe à peu près
dans toutes les parties qui sont
vraiment affectées par cette
guerre d'agression russe.
- Ce matin, on a vu un défilé à
Moscou pour le 9 mai. Vladimir
Poutine rejette toute la
responsabilité de cette guerre
et dit que la menace était trop
importante, donc c'est la faute
de l'Occident. Comment vous
réagissez à ce qui s'est passé
ce matin?
- Mais c'est comme d'habitude.
Il n'a rien dit de nouveau,
il n'a rien dit d'intéressant.
On a entendu cette cassette-là
tourner plusieurs fois,
plusieurs jours, plusieurs
années. C'est toujours la faute
de quelqu'un, mais pas de
Poutine et pas de la Russie.
Ça témoigne sûrement des paroles
d'un dirigeant un peu lunatique
un peu obsédé par le pouvoir et
surtout un dirigeant autoritaire
qui voudrait bien rétablir les
empires.
- Mais ça fait 75 jours que ça
dure, ce conflit, maintenant.
Quel bilan vous faites? Ça doit
être extrêmement fatiguant.
- C'est fatigant, c'est dur,
mais nous, les Ukrainiens,
on n'a pas d'autre choix que
de pousser à la victoire.
Et on le fait avec tous les
réseaux qu'on a ici. On est
vraiment reconnaissant pour
toute l'assistance et l'aide
qu'on reçoit de l'étranger, de
nos alliés. Mais c'est important
aussi de comprendre que le plus
long que ça dure, le plus loin
on sera de la victoire, puisque
Poutine joue à son jeu qu'il a
commencé en 2014, quand il fait
semblant de retirer ses forces,
de localiser la guerre, de
localiser les zones de combat.Et
que l'attention diminue autour
de l'Ukraine, le soutien aussi.
Ça commence à diminuer, puisque
les guerres longues, ça coûte
cher pour tout le monde.
Et donc moi, je crains que c'est
ce jeu-là que Poutine est en
train de jouer avec le monde
entier.
- Vous craignez une fatigue de
lainininininininternationale?
- Une fatigue de la communauté
internationale, une fatigue en
Ukraine aussi et tout ça, c'estr
la victoire de la démocratie.
À ce moment-là, on doit vraiment
mobiliser tous les efforts du
monde entier pour avoir plus
d'armements en Ukraine, pour
avoir vraiment des sanctions
effectives et fortes contre
la Russie et avoir surtout
un soutien économique pour
l'Ukraine. On n'a pas de temps.
On doit avoir cette victoire
le plus vite possible.
- Est-ce que vous pensez que
si l'Occident, et j'inclus le
Canada bien sûr là-dedans, avait
agi plus vite, avait aidé plus
l'Ukraine et plus vite,
on aurait pu sauver des vies
en Ukraine?
- Je suis sûre de ça.
Tout le monde a fait un choix et
maintenant, tout ce qui se passe
ici en Ukraine,
l'Europe, au milieu du XXIe
siècle, c'est la responsabilité
collective du monde entier,
qui n'a pas
- Aujourd'hui, on voit ce qui se
passe encore Marioupol. Il y a
encore des soldats ukrainiens
qui rési'i'i'i'i'i'i'i'i'il va
falloir qu'ils capitulent devant
la Russie? Est-ce que c'est
comme ça que ça va se terminer,
se
- Ils n'ont pas le choix. Encore
une fois, ils n'ont que le choix
de se battre pour soit gagner
une victoire ou se battre à la
mort. Et ce sont les paroles de
ces combattants, de ces soldats
du bataillon d'Azov. Ils disent
qu'ils n'ont pas peur de mourir,
mais ils ont peur d'être pristat
prisonniers par l'armée russe.
- Pourquoi? Parce que ce serait
pire que de mourir, pour eux?
- Ça serait beaucoup plus
pire pour eux. Ils vont être
interrogés, ils vont être
torturés. Ça va être une mort,èt
très douloureuse pour eux et ils
craignent aussi qu'avec leur
identité, si c'est déjà vu paret
les gens proches vont être en
danger aussi.
- Au début de ce conflit, a a a,
vous étiez armée avec une
mitraillette. Ça avait beaucoup
marqué les esprits de voir une
jeune parlementaire comme vous
prendre les armes. Est-ce que
ça vous a servi, finalement?
memememememememememememes.
Je suis très heureuse de ne pas
avoir eu à m'en servir. C'était
s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s,s, le
premier mois de cette guerre...
- Quand les Russes étaient tout
- Quand les Russes étaient
avancés, ils étaient très près
de Kiev, vous avez pu témoigner
quand vous êtes allée à Boutcha
et à Irpin. C'est vraiment très,
très près. C'est pratiquement
Kiev. Donc il y avait ce risque,
ce risque vraiment très haut
et il valait mieux avoir une
arme pour pouvoir se protéger.
À ce moment-là, la situation
a changé. Vous voyez très bien,
la vie continue, la vie revient,
même avec les sons de guerre
un peu en background. Mais de
toute façon, c'est beaucoup plus
calme, c'est beaucoup plus en
sécurité. Donc vous voyez, je
porte pas de sac à main avec un
pistolet dedans. Ce n'est plus
la même chose, mais vraiment,
la guerre continue toujours.
- Vous avez dénoncé justement
les viols comme arme de guerre
de l'armée russe. Quelle est
l'ampleur de ce phénomène?
- Les Russes
le viol comme une arme de
guerre. Ils le faisaient pendant
la Deuxi
Ils le font maintenant aussi.
Donc, rien a changé pour...
vraime
une personne d'être violée,
parce que les Russes,
ils violent les femmes,
les enfants, les hommes.
C'est pire que d'être tué.
Et quand tu es violé,
tu es victime pour le reste
de ta vie, puisque c'était
un crime qui a été commis
contre toi, contre ton corps.
Et ça te marque. En plus,
ces viols-là, c'est pas juste...
- C'est fait pour briser
la résistance.
la rés
briser la personne, c'est fait
pour briser les familles et
le
ces viols, ils se passent
devant les autres gens,
On a plein de cas de viols
qui... où il y avait des filles
leur mère ou les mères qui
étaient violées devant leursilie
ou la communauté doit survivre
à ça, il y a tout un bagageavavl
on ne sait pas quoi faire,
puisqu'il y a
ce sentiment de... "guilt"?
- De honte? De culpabilité?
- De honte et de culpabilité,evt
mes yeux. Je n'ai pas rien pu
faire pour protéger mon enfant,r
protéger cette femme qui est
ma voisine dans ma communauté. e
après avec cela?
Donc, c'est tout... tout ce qui,
c'est tout un long ruban de
problèmes qui vont se déroulerat
des années, peut-être
pendant des générations.
- En terminant, vous pensez que
l'Ukraine va résister jusqu'au
bout? Est-ce qu'elle
cette guerre?
- L'Ukraine doit gagner
cette guerre.
pour les Ukrainiens, mais aussi
pour que le monde entier,
dans lequel on est habitués à
survrivre, reste ce monde
auquel on est habitué, reste
une place de paix, de sécurité.
On doit rétablir la paix,
et c'est ça, ce qui vient
avec la victoire ukrainienne.
- Lesia, merci beaucoup.
- Merci à vous.DeDeDeDeDeDeDeDeé
aujourd'hui. Bonne chance.
- Merci, merci